hallo mehrzad ich habe gleich zwei
fragen wenn dich die erste wäre deine
frau hat ja ein kind bekommen und möchte
ein sieg bei dsds ist ja eigentlich klar
dass familie und freunde eher weniger
zeit haben wird wie gehst du und deine
frau damit um dass sie im grunde das
baby jetzt alleine aufziehen muss wird
wahrscheinlich das erste wort nicht
mitkriegen oder vielleicht doch die
ersten schritte bis dahin daraus noch
ein bisschen aber wenn alles gut läuft
dann bist du ja ein paar jahre lang in
den charts und unterwegs auf touren all
das ja also wie gehst du und deine frau
wo diese situation und die zweite frage
wäre nicht interessiert ob du für den
video drehte eines musikvideos ob du da
bei der produktion im produktion
mitspracherecht hat ist oder ob das
alles schon klar
doch das machen und solltest was hier
gesagt wurde vielen dank für deine
antworten ja manchmal die erste
also ich habe natürlich zeit für meine
familie
es ist natürlich nicht mehr so viel zeit
wie vorher aber ich weiß halt profis
mache lieber ob ich meine eigene zeit
und weiß aber dass da meine familie bis
heute meinen kleinen im endeffekt besser
geht dabei und ich werde natürlich meine
familie auch so häufig wie es geht mit
nehmen zu drews und auch mal zu
shows und die kommen ja auch gerne mal
mit so es ist nicht so wie sehen uns
immer noch sehr häufig ich war die
letzte woche fast 7 abend zu hause
und auf dem eine auf eine andere frage
noch mal zurückzukommen
beim videodreh ist natürlich schon vorab
schon alles ein bisschen geplant ist
aber ich habe immer mittendrin
mitspracherecht gehabt das heißt wenn
wir etwas nicht gefallen hat konnte ich
das zu wort bringen aber ich weiß bis
dahin mit allem zufrieden und bin
einfach glücklich dass wir sagen auch im
kasten ist